مع توقف الحرب الروسية في أوكرانيا ،
وقالت الولايات المتحدة إن الروح المعنوية مشكلة
للقوات الروسية ، علمت
CNN باجتماع نادر في موسكو بين الولايات المتحدة
والمسؤولين العسكريين الروس والذي
احتوى وفقًا لقراءة الولايات المتحدة
للاجتماع على اقتباس يكشف
لحظة من اللواء الروسي.  إيفجيني إيلين ،
وهو جنرال يتمتع بخبرة واسعة في
التعامل مع الأمريكيين مع
انتهاء الاجتماع ، تقول القراءات إن أحد
الملحقين من الجانب الأمريكي سأل عرضًا عن
جذور عائلة ألين في أوكرانيا وفقًا
للقراءة ، قال المسؤول الأمريكي إن
سلوك الجنرال الرزين أصبح فجأة
محمرًا وأجاب ألين مضطربًا
ولد في أوكرانيا وذهب إلى المدرسة
في دونيتسك ثم قال
وفقًا للقراءة إن الوضع في أوكرانيا
مأساوي وأنا مكتئب للغاية
قبل الخروج دون
مصافحة كتب الملحق في قراءات
النار في عينيه ومربكًا.
غادر السلوك قشعريرة برد
، وعادة ما تكون مكتوبة اجتماعات العمود الفقري مع المسؤولين
الروس ولكن ال  قال ملحقان إنهما
لم يسبق لهما أن شاهدا مثل هذا الغضب من قبل
نظرائهما الروس في
اجتماع رسمي ، وخلصت قراءة المسؤولين
إلى أنه من الواضح على الأقل
أن المشاكل المعنوية بين
القوات الروسية لا تقتصر على القوات الموجودة في الخطوط الأمامية.
لا يشرح
المسؤولون الأمريكيون ولا
يشرحون بشكل قاطع سلوك إيلين ، فهذه القراءات
عادة ما تكون حساسة للغاية بحيث لا يمكن جعلها
قراءات عامة من هذا النوع
مهمة
لأنها تعطينا نظرة ثاقبة محتملة
حول
ما يفكر فيه الروس حقًا ،
لكنها تظهر أيضًا أن هناك بعض
نوع من المشاكل المعنوية داخل
التسلسل الهرمي الروسي ،
وربما تمتد حتى القمة ،
لم تستجب وزارة الدفاع الروسية
لطلب CNN للتعليق
على الاجتماع أو القراءة ، لكن
الكرملين نفى تقارير عن انخفاض الروح المعنوية
بين  قواتها في أوكرانيا قد
تضطر إلى الشك في هذه المعلومات
لديك للشك فيها ولديك  التفكير مرتين
فيما إذا كان هذا
صحيحًا أم لا
حيث تواجه روسيا مقاومة شديدة من
القوات الأوكرانية إذا كان الأمريكيون على
صواب ومعنوياتهم مشكلة ، فهذا
تحد لا يستطيع الروس تحمله ،
لقد رأينا مؤشرات متزايدة على أن
الروح المعنوية وتماسك الوحدة يمثلان مشكلة
و  نعم ، هذا يُترجم تمامًا إلى
قضايا الفعالية العسكرية المحتملة
الآن ، يتم إبعاد الروس
وفقًا للأوكرانيين
الذين ساعدتهم فيضان النهر الحضري
مما يجعل العمليات القتالية
للروس أكثر صعوبة ويجب أن
أقول إنها كانت شرسة  قتال ، نحن على بعد
10 أميال من هذا الموقع
ويمكننا سماع ذلك يمكننا سماع القصف
بلا شك في كلا الاتجاهين
حتى نسمع أه بعض نيران الأسلحة الصغيرة ، حيث
تدور معركة شرسة للغاية على 80 في المائة
من تلك المدينة التي تمت استعادتها وفقًا لـ  قامت
الشرطة أيضًا بإخراج مقطع فيديو
لأنفسهم وهم يقومون بدوريات ، لكن بالطبع
قد يسير هذا في الاتجاه المعاكس في أي وقت ولكن
ماكاروف بلدة أخرى في الغرب كثيرًا
مزيدًا من الغرب أه أسفل طريق حاسم
خارج المدينة إلى الغرب ، تم
الاستيلاء عليه أيضًا وفقًا
للأوكرانيين أمس.
تمسكوا بخطوطهم ليس فقط ضد
الروس بل ضد الروس البيلا إذا
جاءوا كما توقع
المحللون الغربيون بالتأكيد وهنا في أوكرانيا أه
عسكريون قلقون حقًا من أنه إذا
انضمت بيلاروسيا إلى هذه الحرب فقد يقلب
التوازن من حيث العدد وقوة النيران
و  اجعل كييف ضعيفًا مرة
أخرى بام
[موسيقى]